hey this voicemail I have to play for
you today is really emblematic of the
sort of arrogance that we now see among
many on the right this is a caller named
Juan who used to call in and say he was
the anti-intellectual now he just says
it's Juan and it turns out Juan realized
he knows more than his doctors this this
is without a shred of irony guys take a
listen to this
hey David it's me again Juan right
Healthcare is a scam
anecdotally most of the doctors that
I've had to deal with are ignorant
and I've had to correct them several
times so anecdotally and maybe you're
dealing with the wrong doctors Juan
and at the end of my interaction with
them
they've ended up agreeing with me
uh
uh they have no clue
they have a set of knowledge and ideas
in their in their minds
that they learned in school and college
and university right
but there's a lot of research
that is a lot more up to date than what
they think now of course any good doctor
is staying up to date on the research of
course and in my experience when I
mentioned to a doctor hey you know I
recently read about X whether it's in
dermatology or whatever they say oh yeah
yeah yeah I'm familiar with that so the
idea that doctors no less than Juan
because they go based on what they
learned in medical school 5 10 20 30
years ago but Juan is doing internet
research this is this is the height of
the type of arrogance that got us the
Ivermectin stuff nebulizing hydrogen
peroxide
Etc
uh
I think Health Care needs to be
abolished wow and totally built from the
ground up
so anyway listen guys we're up against
some pretty serious stuff and with not a
shred of irony confidently Juan saying
the fact that he looked stuff up on the
internet
and
knew more than his doctors I guess is
evidence that the medical field is bad I
mean it's it's crazy it's really really
crazy and this is what we're up against
we've got a great bonus show for you
today Joe Biden is facing a squeeze on
defense spending from the left and from
the right it's very interesting
politically what's going on Tennessee is
trying to find a loophole in order to be
able to ban same-sex marriage the
problem is they might legalize child
Brides In so doing it's Bonkers what's
going on there and we'll talk about Alex
Jones facing jail time at this point uh
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com to
get instant access go to
davidpackman.com free membership to
request a free membership and anybody
who wants can gift memberships to others
by checking the this is a gift box when
signing up at joinpakman.com I will see
you then